el amoniaco es una base débil que cuando
reacciona con agua el agua funcionará
como un ácido te brondsted lowry donará
un protón al amoniaco y el amoniaco lo
aceptará porque funciona como una base
de brondsted laurie entonces un par de
electrones en el nitrógeno tomarán este
protón dejando estos electrones en el
oxígeno y si protón amos el amoniaco
formamos el ión amonio nh4 más entonces
este par de electrones en el nitrógeno
tomaron este protón y formaron este
enlace y estos electrones en azul se
quedaron con el oxígeno que ya tenía dos
pares de electrones libres a su
alrededor y ahora tiene otro par de
electrones lo que le da una carga forma
negativa así hemos formado el guión
amonio n
cuatro más y un guión hidróxido o h
menos entonces si el amoniaco funciona
como una base de brondsted lowry
este es nuestro ácido conjugado el
amonio y como el agua funciona como un
ácido t brondsted laurie el a nyon
hidróxido es su base conjugado ahora en
lugar del amoniaco usemos una base
general si una taza reacciona con agua
le quitará un protón y formará de h más
y al quitarle un protón al h2o nos queda
o h menos ahora una vez que la reacción
llega al equilibrio podemos escribir la
expresión de equilibrio que en este caso
escape porque estamos hablando de una
base
es la constante de bassi cidad constante
de pacífica
o también se le conoce como constante de
disociación de la base constante de
disociación
de la paz
que es igual a la concentración de los
productos sobre la concentración de los
reactivos entonces tenemos la
concentración de ph más
la concentración de o menos entre la
concentración de los reactivos sin tomar
en cuenta el agua así que solo tenemos
la concentración de la base
a mayor k t más fuerte es la base y
habrá más productos lo escribiré base
fuerte
el mayor valor de café ahora comparemos
el amoniaco con otra base débil conocida
como anilina nh3 es el amoniaco y su cap
de este 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 mientras
que la anilina es 66 h5n2 y observen que
tiene un café de 4.3 por 10 a la menos
10 es más pequeño que 1.8 por 10 a la
menos 5 así que el amoniaco tiene un
valor más alto de café y por lo tanto
aunque las dos son bases débiles el
amoniaco es una base más fuerte que la
anilina recuerden que cuando hablamos de
k
también hablamos del pk
así que en este caso como estamos
hablando de café
ahora hablemos del pecado pp es igual a
menos el logaritmo de k b y supongamos
que queremos encontrar el pkt del
amoniaco todo lo que tenemos que hacer
es sustituir el café entonces nos queda
es igual a menos el logaritmo de 1.8 por
10 a la menos 5 vamos a resolverlo con
la calculadora menos logaritmo de 1.8
por 10 a la menos 5 es igual a 4.74 el
pkt del amoniaco es igual a 4.74 y
podemos hacer lo mismo para la anilina
usando este valor tecate con lo que
obtendremos un pp de 9.37 entonces al
comparar dos bases débiles como amoníaco
y anilina el amoniaco es más fuerte
tiene el valor más alto de café pero
observen que tiene el valor más bajo de
pkt ahora hagamos un cálculo para una
solución de amoniaco el problema nos
pide que calculemos el ph de una
solución acuosa 0.500 molar de amoniaco
así que tenemos amoniaco en agua nh3 +
h2o el amoniaco aceptará un protón del
agua y se convertirá en nh 4 + amonio y
si el agua pierde un protón h2o se
convierte en h - entonces escribamos la
concentración inicial para el amoníaco
inicialmente tenemos una concentración
0.500 molar y si todavía no ocurre la
reacción la concentración de nuestros
productos
pero no ha pasado nada así que la
concentración del amoniaco y del
hidróxido es cero ahora pensemos en el
cambio como el amoniaco nh3 se
transforma en nh 4 más la concentración
del amoniaco que se perdió es la misma
concentración que ganó el amonio
entonces podemos representar esa
concentración con una equis perdemos una
cierta concentración de amoniaco y
ganamos la misma concentración en el
amonio y lo mismo ocurre con el
hidróxido así que también tenemos más x
ahora vamos con el equilibrio la
concentración de amoniaco al equilibrio
es igual a 0.50 0 - x
para el amonio nos queda x y para el
hidróxido también nos queda x escribamos
la expresión de equilibrio café es igual
a la concentración de los productos
nh 4 más
la concentración de hidróxido entre la
concentración de amoniaco recuerden que
el agua no se toma en cuenta entonces
entre la concentración de amoniaco
ahora al equilibrio la concentración de
amonio es x x y lo mismo tenemos para la
concentración de hidróxido
entre la concentración del amoniaco en
el equilibrio que es de 0.5 00 - x
entonces 0.50 0 - x
y esto es igual a la constante de bassi
cidad del amoniaco regresamos a nuestra
tabla el amoniaco tiene un valor de café
de 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 entonces esto
es igual a 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 y
nuevamente para que sea más fácil
supongamos que x es mucho más pequeño
que 0.500 molar entonces si tenemos 0.50
0 - x como estamos suponiendo que x es
muy pequeño esto es muy parecido a 0.50
0 así que la ecuación nos queda como 1.8
por 10 a la menos 5 es igual a x al
cuadrado entre 0.50 0
ahora calculemos el valor de x x
cuadrada es igual a 1.8 por 10 a la
menos 5 por 0.5 00 esto es igual a 9.0
por 10 a la menos 6 y finalmente
saquemos la raíz cuadrada de 9.0 por 10
a la menos 6 para saber el valor de x
usemos la calculadora la raíz cuadrada
de 9.0 por 10 a la menos 6 es igual a
0.00 3x es igual a 0.00 30 y vamos a
recordar a qué se refiere esta x x en
este caso es la concentración de iones
hidróxido con lo que podemos calcular el
ph
qué es lo que nos piden en el problema
entonces x es la concentración molar de
iones hidróxido y nuestro objetivo es
calcular el ph de la solución entonces
primero necesitamos calcular el ph el p
h es igual a menos el logaritmo de la
concentración de iones hidróxido
entonces menos logaritmo de 0.00 30
usemos la calculadora menos logaritmo de
0.00 30 es igual a 2.52 el pp o h es
igual a 2.52 y para encontrar el ph sólo
necesitamos restar 14 porque te h más p
h es igual a 14.00 entonces simplemente
sustituimos el valor de p
h y nos queda de h 2.52 es igual a 14.00
así que el ph es igual a 14 menos 2.52
que es igual a 11.48 este es el ph para
nuestra solución de amoniaco